un point presse qui restera dans les
livres d'histoire la présidente
démocrate de la chambre des
représentants appelle une nouvelle fois
il décision irrévocable
magna le seuil franchi et d'une telle
gravité qu'il n'est pas question que ce
président soit autorisé à prendre des
décisions ni même à mobiliser la moindre
trouble de ses trains piste et
maintenant que va-t-il se passer
aujourd'hui qui sait mais ce que nous
savons c'est qu'il doit être maîtrisée
tout comme fin 2019 les démocrates
invoque le 25e amendement de la
constitution américaine
le comportement de donald trump décrié
après son discours musclé devant ses
supporters et les manifestations qui ont
suivi à washington au sein du capitole
jeudi depuis maintenant bien plus d'un
an qu'il n'est pas apte à servir qu'il
n'est pas apte à servir
c'est l'un des présidents les plus
incompétents de l'histoire des états
unis d'amérique
la question est de savoir aujourd'hui ce
qui va se passer les 14 ou 13 prochains
jours d'être clé le 20 janvier jour où
le président élu joe biden prêtera
serment d'ici cette date
donald trump est capable de prendre des
décisions importantes
il a annoncé ne pas vouloir assister à
la prochaine passation du pouvoir
une première pour un président américain
depuis 1869 annonce faite par le
milliardaire républicain sur twitter
vendredi le réseau social qui est des
conséquences de cette décision a donc
décidé d'exclure de façon permanente
l'homme aux 88 millions d'abonnés après
avoir examiné de près les récentes 8 du
comte de donald trump et le contexte qui
les entoure en particulier la façon dont
ils sont reçus et interprétés sur
twitter et en dehors
nous avons suspendu définitivement le
compte en raison du risque de nouvelles
incitations à la violence
après les évènements du mercredi 6
janvier qui ont fait cinq morts
le ministère de la justice annonce et 15
inculpation dans celle de richard bach
n'être parvenu à s'introduire dans les
bureaux de la présidente de la chambre
des représentants alors que le parlement
validé dans le même temps la victoire de
joe biden l'homme inculpé pour intrusion
violente
d'autres arrestations sont à prévoir a
annoncé le bureau du procureur fédéral
de washington
drapeau du capitole en berne
nancy pelosi a confié également s'être
entretenu avec l'armée américaine pour
s'assurer que donald trump ne puisse pas
utiliser les précieux code nucléaire